des slips des chaussettes des bonnets
bonjour je suis Fabrice pialo et vous me
connaissez surtout parce que je suis le
papa de footix vous voyez que je veux
dire c'est la carte visite mondiale ou
quoi c'est le pour une carte de visite
elle est vraiment mondiale celle-là elle
va être vu par combien de milliards je
sais pas ils estiment autour de 37 40
milliards de personnes au niveau
du Sud quoi
je me rappelle très bien le journaliste
je me rappelle que j'avais un track fou
c'est la première fois que je passais à
la télé
[Musique]
cette 3D était assez spéciale
non plus
montage c'est après un coup de vieux
quoi on m'a appelé l'agence qui
s'appelle dragon rouge avec qui je
travaille en freelance je voulais pas le
faire je voulais pas le faire parce que
je vous dis je n'étais pas j'étais pas
spécialement chaud j'étais débordé de
boulons j'étais pas fan de foot et puis
on m'a un peu forcé la main quoi j'ai
fait ça presque la dernière 48 heures
je fais ça dans le dans le train rapide
voilà j'ai fait quelques gros bars comme
je fais d'habitude sur calque au bleu et
voilà il est sorti il est sorti tout
seul je me suis dit il y a que un coq
qui peut marcher pour la France et j'ai
fait encore que assez simple facile à
dessiner et le plus dynamique possible
donc voilà une espèce de fusée et jouer
sur les couleurs le bleu le rouge le
jaune pour le bec et le blanc c'était le
ballon ça fait à peu près c'est bien
bien 15 ans que je peux ressortissant
c'est à cause de vous là que je
[Applaudissements]
le tout premier
le méchant et puis après là j'ai
commencé
après je vais dessiner des
voilà
après c'est des premières vision quoi en
fait
avoir cette gueule footix c'est le
nombre de la mascotte du Mondial 98 elle
faisait hier sa première sortie
officielle hors Paris c'était à Istres
dans les Bouches-du-Rhône à l'occasion
du tournoi international de Pentecôte
les Français donc mais aussi des
Tchèques des Italiens des Portugais des
Algériens moi je travaille à la maison
je suis freelance
et les gosses étaient là et donc ils ont
ils ont assisté à la Genèse quoi mon
fils se disait c'est à 8 ans mais c'est
mon père qui a fait footix donc ça
finissait un peu gilet quoi personne ne
voulait le croire il flotte un petit air
de coupe du monde que footix la mascotte
du Mondial 98 je connaissais pas du tout
ça
pour favoris foot peut donc alors sortir
de son ballon le 10e tournoi
international d'Istres peut commencer
c'était la première sortie officielle de
la mascotte en proie je passais assez
souvent à la télé au début surtout pour
répéter toujours pareil quoi mais bon
c'était sympa mais puis il y avait aussi
les autres télévision
internationales je me rappelle une fois
il y avait télé italienne et japonaise
qui était là qui passe aux disputer mais
presque pour avoir le c'était assez
c'était rigolo on n'en pouvait plus
quand même
piano vous êtes né le 23 janvier 57 à
Montpellier vous êtes marié à Catherine
et papa de Théo et Lola
vous le dites haut et fort Fabrice vous
êtes un autodidacte et surtout en
cuisine
dans une section de cuivre derrière un
groupe de rock chilien qui était parti
en tournée dans le nord de l'Europe et
puis en fait ce genre de tournée j'ai
dépensé plus de sous à tourner que en
fait je devais des sous autour de moi en
arrivant à Paris j'étais bloqué et donc
voilà et puis un ami m'a dit mais toi tu
dessines toujours en fait je me suis
rendu compte que je pouvais gagner en
faisant des dessins que je mettais
des mois en juin son prix de crayon
correspond complètement à une cible et
ce qui fait que maintenant mais il est
présent un petit peu partout dans la
grande distribution un défaut d'avoir un
Picasso chez vous vous avez un piano
dans le frigo
[Musique]
ils ont mis toute la pub
cette dessinateur qui a fait Prosper
les courses car c'est l'occasion de
retrouver dans les linéaires tous ces
petits copains
voilà un petit une petite glace de chez
Nico babyco avec le petit personnage qui
s'appelle mythe de Miko après ouais
Captain Cho comme on voit dans le
reportage la gardienne shop de teen
musclé au prospère Sironimo
après j'ai fait des masques pour casino
pour Carrefour pour Cora je travaille
pour plein de pour après pour Daddy ça
c'est si on immo
en fait j'avais créé
j'avais créé les premières
moutures il y a deux tours
du coussin de luchard
du McDonald's des slips des chaussettes
des bonnets
pour pour plus tard et
lui
le footing
par rapport à ma carrière de Graphis
c'est quelque chose qui est assez sympa
rien que pour le fait que mon fils
on était dans les tribunaux officiels
avec Chirac à juste derrière nous à la
finale contre le Brésil rien que mon
fils a assisté
de foot voilà quoi c'était c'était un
régal quoi
[Musique]